a lawsuit by MGM Resorts against
survivors of the worst mass shooting in
modern US history is drawing outrage the
company claims it cannot be held
financially liable for the Las Vegas
massacre last October its lawsuit
against hundreds of survivors seeks to
have a federal judge throughout their
claims against MGM and stop new ones
Jericka Duncan shows us how an obscure
law that could bolster MGM's case is
playing out Tirico good morning good
morning very interesting story here the
MGM they owned the Las Vegas concert
venue where the October shooting took
place now it also owns the hotel from
which the gunman opened fire killing 58
people and injuring more than 500 even
so the company believes it doesn't know
any of the victims a dime my first
thoughts were were probably gonna die
nine months after the Las Vegas shooting
Lisa finds physical injuries have healed
but her emotional and psychological
wounds have not the co-founder of route
91 strong a group of survivors of the
concert shooting last October fine says
MGM's latest legal maneuver makes her
feel sick to her stomach feels like
bullets are flying at my head right now
in two federal lawsuits filed against
hundreds of shooting victims last week
MGM says it cannot be held liable for
deaths injuries or other damages arising
from the shooting it cites the Safety
Act the law encourages security firms to
develop new anti-terrorism measures in
exchange companies who use those
security firms are immune from claims
MGM says it cannot be sued for the
shooting because the security firm it
hired for the concert was certified
under the Safety Act this has actually
triggered PTSD for a lot of the victims
attorney Brian Claypool represents more
than 75 survivors he was also at the
Music Festival when gunman Stephen
paddock opened fire Claypool argues this
Safety Act does not protect MGM they are
only immunized from liability if
is an act of terrorism but MGM was
responsible for security at the Mandalay
Bay Hotel where Patek amassed his
arsenal undetected CBS News legal
analyst Ricky Clemens says MGM's lawyers
made a smart legal move but questions
the optics if you make the public think
that you're suing people or their
families who are dead or seriously
injured to me that's a PR disaster in a
statement MGM says it hopes its federal
court filings will lead to a timely
resolution for all the victims the
company claims more than 2500 people
have already sued or threatened to sue
them over the shooting and obviously it
doesn't look good but I think MGM is
hoping that with it with it going to the
federal courts that the DOJ will then
use funds from what is called the Crime
Victims Fund yeah it doesn't look good
riki claimants husband used to say may
be lawful but it sure looks awful he's a
commissioner Thank You jury Co